Hey, today we're going to talk about how
we taught agents to use good retrieval
or how we call it internally closing the
Oracle gap with knowledge agents.
>> I'm Hannah. I'm an AI engineer at Mix
bread and I'm leading the agentic search
at Mix bread.
>> Yeah, I'm Amir. I'm the co-founder of
Mix bread and let's jump into it. So, we
have seen over the past years with the
LLMs just getting better and better that
the reasoning capabilities of the models
is growing exponentially. So, just think
back how good GPT-3.5 was and how good
GPT-5.5 was, right? So, I can clearly
exponential curve. But, if you look at
search over the last 20 years basically,
we see that
it's improving, but it's improving very
very slowly.
So, there's a huge gap between how
basically LLMs and the reasoning is
evolving and how retrieval is evolving.
But, the retrieval tools are the main
access pattern for this reasoning there
to get the right knowledge and to be
truly useful beyond code like in legal
work, in finance work and so on and so
forth. Internally, we call this gap
happening right now between reasoning
and search the knowledge gap. And it's
not just one obscure theory of ours. We
see that actually with real benchmarks
and real tasks that this gap exists in
real world as well. Let's take
two benchmarks here, BroSque Plus and
Office QA Pro. BroSque Plus is like a
browsing benchmark where we have
pre-complex queries and a corpus of
100,000 documents and we just try to
answer these questions. It's like real
world deep search task basically and
Office QA Pro
which has the treasuries of the US
treasuries of the past
um
100 years basically
and we ask really complex question over
this. Office QA Pro was created by
Databricks and BrowseComp was created by
OpenAI and BrowseComp Plus is a version
of it with a fixed size corpus while
BrowseComp was over the open web.
And we see here's a Oracle performance
in dotted lines and Oracle means what is
the maximum theoretical performance of
the models if you would put in the right
documents with the question with with
the question. We see for
Office for BrowseComp it's 93%
and for Office QA Pro it's 64%.
And now we take something like Codex
with its default tools
and want to see hey, what is the
performance this tools get right now?
And you see there's a sharp drop in the
quality of the answers Codex produces.
For BrowseComp it's nine points and for
Office QA Pro it's eight points. So we
see that the models are extremely
capable if they would get the right
documents but if you put them into
the noisy corpus the performance drops
sharply.
Meaning that actually the bottleneck
here is not the reasoning. It's actually
the access to the right knowledge it
needs to answer this question. So we see
this knowledge gap in real world.
And if you would just drop in way better
search using Mixbread with just a search
tool using latent interaction we can
recover most of the performance. So for
BrowseComp the difference between the
Oracle and the
uh GPT-5 with Mixbread is just three
point and for Office QA Pro we even
almost completely closed the gap. With
giving the model better search tool we
can recover most of the knowledge gap.
But looking at the queries the model
asks or writes right now to the search
system,
it gets super super interesting.
So, here's an example query we found
uh during some benchmarking, which is
senator woman questions billionaires not
a company then okay thank you staff will
check hearing.
It's basically gibberish, right? If you
have a search system which wants to have
neural questions or semantic question
and just gets these keywords over
keywords,
it gets confused. And the reason why the
models write these type of queries is
they're mostly trained for coding task,
like for coding agents, which are then
optimized for code base exploration
using tools like grep. And grep
just tries to find regular expressions,
right? So, the model tries to just write
as many expression it thinks are in the
document to find the right thing. The
second thing is the models are trained
to use the web pretty efficiently.
And
to use the web tools properly, which are
highly optimized for humans, they try to
mimic human-like query patterns. So,
just keyword on keyword on keyword. And
number three, obviously, is the
benchmark bias. Most benchmarks we have
right now, like Beer, Nano Beer, use
Caveman's style queries, which are
entity-based queries
that structurally favor heavily BM25.
So, right now, the agent guesses the
keywords to actually increase the
overlap between the query and documents
and can't really use powerful search
tools properly.
>> This motivated us to make our own search
agent, to teach it to use powerful
search properly, especially to use the
right search tools for different use
cases.
Um and to work beyond code search for
knowledge work. And most importantly,
the agent should be precise, fast, and
cheap. The first step for building this
agent was to define a very powerful
harness.
Um [clears throat] our harness is fully
built on a mixed back platform.
Our agent has four main search tools,
which are overview search.
This is used as a very wide semantic
search where the agent receives up to 50
retrieve chunks.
Um and it sees only summaries of the
chunk contents
to really have just like an overview of
the corpus every
uh what exists and to not fill up the
context too much.
Then there is the main semantic search
tool where the agent gets the full
payload of
the top 10 retrieve chunks.
Um
it has a filter chunks tool where it can
sort sort and find chunks based on
metadata facets. And of course we also
have a grep tool for the keyword match
searches.
Our um agent loop, the harness itself is
very simple and short cuz the agent
should be fast.
But we still wanted it to uh
have a lot of exploration possibilities.
That's why we decided to um define that
it has a maximum four search rounds, but
within each search round it can have
parallel searches.
So it can start several search at that
searches at once.
Um initially our
agent sees the user query, but also
already um
results from an initial semantic search
on the user query plus um hints on which
metadata facets are available.
Um so that based on this preview of the
corpus
the agent can start its search planning.
It splits its search intent into maximum
four queries
um which cover separate aspects. And
then for each query and each search
intent, it will
pick the best tool.
Um as you can see like an example here
on the right.
Then when um the
results of the tools are returned to the
agent via deduplicating chunks, so that
it's never seeing several chunks
um several times to not fill up the
context.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
and yeah, the next search one can start,
and as soon as the agent has enough
evidence to answer the user query, it
submits its ranking. Um yeah, we are
just outputs all the chunks that are
relevant to the query in a plausible
ranking.
So, why does this harness encourages
better semantics queries and like better
use of search tools?
Um there are five more main points for
this,
which is first the goal framing. The
agent has to articulate articulate what
evidence it needs before writing the
query.
Um then the different tools are very
important, so it can really use semantic
search only if it needs aspects, and
also only use a scrap when it needs
exact keyword matching.
Um
then the
way in which we frame the task of query
uh writing is an important point. We
kind of trick the um model into not
thinking it has to write the typical
BM25 base query by just instructing it
to write one concise sentence describing
what it wants to find,
instead of directly instructing write a
search query, so it cannot fall into
this old pattern.
Um
then we put also provide examples in a
prompt just to show the a few good
queries and also how to divide an input
query into different aspects to explore
um the corpus.
Yeah.
What also helps is that we provide the
original original query semantic search
results. So, it can see what the corpus
is about and really define um see the
language, define where to dig deeper in
which aspect.
The second important step into building
our own search agent was of course the
training itself.
So, here for training, we just decided
to have a very small LLM to make the
agent even faster.
So, we are training the small agent um
to optimize the search strategy itself
to have better tool choice,
um higher quality of semantic queries,
more exploration ranking, and to be more
efficient.
So, the first step in training is um
supervised fine-tuning with a larger
teacher LLM.
And then we
uh did on-policy reinforcement learning
with an own search reward.
Our search reward
is a combination of both of a retrieval
reward and a trajectory reward.
The retrieval reward um
is based on like the metric result,
typical retrieval metric results like we
call it NDCG, that's the agent's final
ranked list achieves.
Plus also um
an LLM retrieval judging.
We had thought like it gets several
rubrics where it decides um
if the rubrics is hit or not, the rubric
is hit or not, which are
if the agent result relevant for this
query, are all chunks relevant,
and is the ranking itself plausible.
For the trajectory reward, we also using
an LLM judge and here um
is the point to like really improve the
tool queries, make it more efficient and
to um
improve the quality of the queries.
Of course, like we have rubrics that are
where the judge is deciding if the query
is really a natural sentence. Also, if
the amount of exploration is
sufficient, is it too much or too less.
Here you can see an example trajectory.
You see that in the beginning we have
the initial search and the initial
metadata hints.
Um then the agent did four parallel
searches in the first round and then a
second round just a simple grep tool.
And here's an extract of um a
trajectory.
Here we see the agent queries.
Um the input query is on the left. This
is a very long query typical
rambling style query from the Oblique
Congress benchmark.
And yeah, we see the agent queries here
for the first semantic search tool. It's
really a sentence describing what it
wants to find and not a weird keywordy
added behind each other
formulation.
The grep tools of course are like
typical keyword patterns, which is
exactly as intended.
Our trained agent is not released yet,
unfortunately. However, we have some
intermediate results.
Here on the left side for the Oblique
Congress benchmark,
we see that we achieved an NDCG of 10 at
10 of 0.4, which is a huge jump um
towards the model that performed best on
the paper of this benchmark, which is
the GPT multi-hop agent,
and which achieves 0.
18.
On the right side, you can see the
result of our beta version of the search
agent, which we have right now in
production. It's the mixed better
genetic search.
And this agent is top one on the
snowflakes match QA benchmark, achieving
an accuracy of 93.4
when we give the Gemini 3.5 flash model
our genetic search as search tool.
And this
uh
this performance was also achieved while
having way less effort than comparable
LLMs with other search agents. You can
check out the match QA leaderboard.
These results show that there's still a
lot of room for improvement when it
comes to huge language models
and their search tools.
And if you want to be part of pushing
the boundaries of retrieval even
further,
um we are happy awaiting your
application.